some houses rise to power through
strength others through wealth House
Frey gained its title through cunning
centuries ago its founder looked at a
map and noticed how the Trident spheres
the neck cutting off the north from the
south he realized that a river of gold
would flow to the man who owned the
right bridge across the water it took
the phrase three generations to complete
the forefathers vision a massive arch of
smooth grey rock wide enough for two
wagons to pass abreast when they were
done they built high curtain walls deep
moats and heavy gates to protect the
approaches and put up squat ugly
formidable keeps on either bank the
twins commanding both road and river
with arrow slits murder holes and
portcullises the twins ensure that no
one crosses without begging the phrase
leave and pay the phrase toe the plan
worked the family grew rich and powerful
exacting gold from lords merchants and
poor farmers a good thing too given the
number of phrase the bridge has to
support the current Lord Walder Frey has
seen over ninety nine days and sired
near as many children trueborn are
otherwise a shameful thing in any other
Lord but Walder Frey possesses no shame
a dangerous thing for any other Lord but
Walder Frey has no concern for heirs of
fear of their impatience perhaps Lord
Frey thinks to outlast them all given
the infighting he encourages among them
perhaps he will whatever the case House
Frey does nothing so well as survive
when the Ironborn conquered and raised
the river lands the phrase hid in their
castle when Aegon and house Tully swept
the Ironborn back to their islands the
phrase hid in their castle when my
ancestor demanded their allegiance as
Aegon's new lord paramount of the
Trident the phrase bent the knee from
their castle perhaps then we should not
have been surprised when my father Lord
hoster Tully called his banners against
the Mad King and Lord Walder didn't
answer the Baratheon's Starks errands
and Tully's some of the oldest and
greatest houses of Westeros fought and
bled for the cause of justice while
House Frey hid in its castle and waited
no doubt of Rhaegar had won at the
Trident
Lord Walder would have given him safe
passage into the north to destroy the
rest of my husband's northern army for a
fair price but Rhaegar fell and lo and
behold the Frey army appeared to render
aid to our already victorious forces
many sniggered that Lord Walder had been
waiting for his army to come of age
having fielded it out of his own
britches my own father named him the
late Lord Frey to the other Lords
amusement a slight that pricks Lord
Walder to this day in many ways however
Lord Walder was wise we had no guarantee
of victory and had he fought with us
from the outset and we failed
he would have lost the bridge his family
was so proud of more pride than honor
those should be the words of house free
yet part of me wonders if Lord alder
waited not out of fear but hope that we
would be destroyed leaving him to assume
my family's place as Lord paramount of
the Trident to buy the respect they've
always wanted but refused to earn
no not even Lord Walder could be so
disloyal